how much money were you spending on
drugs a month do you even know
no i'd say about
five to ten grand so how bad did this
addiction get
i was taking 18 to 20 pills a day
18 to 20.
yeah and no one knew
no one knew stacy dash opens up about
her battle with addiction past traumas
and her road to recovery i thought you
know what i'm going to let people know
what i've been through
tell the truth about my life
on thursday's episode of the dr oz show
the 54 year old actress gets candid
about her past claiming that both her
parents were addicts dash says she first
tried drugs when she was eight years old
and when she was 16 her mom gave her her
first line of cocaine both my parents
were drug addicts
my father was a heroin addict
my mother
i don't know she did her and i know she
smoked crack and did a lot of coke it's
a topic the actress opened up to et
about back in 2016 while promoting her
book there goes my social life from
clueless to conservative there are so
many kids who
when they see their parents in that
struggle it's like that fork in the road
it either scares you straight or it
leads you down the same path and it led
you down the same path for a little
while
yeah
until i had my son dash also says trauma
in her life happened early telling dr oz
she was molested when she was four i
didn't really remember until i was 17
when i tried to kill myself it was at
that time that i remembered that that
happened to me and
i
had already been very angry i was very
angry
i became angry at i'd say around the age
of 10 or 11 which is when my mother
finally left my father even though my
home was unstable and my father was a
heroin addict i knew he loved me he just
couldn't beat it he couldn't overcome
the addiction
dash adds that she ran away from home
and would party and says she was in an
abusive relationship in her early 20s
i mean he would beat me so bad that i
couldn't get out of bed for two weeks i
couldn't walk
what did those abusive relationships
teach you that i didn't value myself
that i need to value myself later on
dash got sober but after 20 years clean
she says she relapsed when she was
prescribed vicodin to help with her
painful fibroid cysts and became
addicted i'm not blaming the doctors at
all because it was my choice to take
more you know it was my choice to take
that extra one even though i wasn't in
pain
i chose to do that
because the viking filled that hole
inside of me
it filled that anger it calmed that
anger down it
slowed my brain down it gave me the ease
so that i could deal with life
at one point the clueless star said she
was taking 18 to 20 pills a day but no
one knew adding that her addiction
caused her to lose everything how much
money were you spending on drugs a month
do you even know
no i'd say about
five to ten grand
as for what stopped her i almost died
my kidneys were so infected that my
blood was septic
and my organs were shutting down so i
got rushed to the hospital
oh my goodness and i had to have a full
blood transfusion
and i was in there for three weeks and
by the grace and mercy of god
i lived
after she left the hospital the actress
says she continued to abuse drugs before
entering a rehab facility it wasn't
until the last 10 days that i finally
said
oh snap
i'm an addict
today dash is five years sober greatest
blessing is that not only have i
been able to be honest with myself
and become a better person
i've been able to
understand my parents
and that they did love me
and that they were doing the best they
could and they were just sick
they were addicted
the former fox news commentator now
credits her faith for helping her get
sober and hopes that by sharing her
story she can help people battling
similar demons
there is no shame
in being an addict there is no shame
in getting help
because
that's what we need
and for people who are not addicts
i would ask them to please
look at people with more compassion
and empathy
understanding
because they need help
they need help can't do it on their own
you